steve ryan congratulations you have
forged your way into the final round of
this competition the first two rounds
you came to our forge and used our tools
and equipment to forge signature blades
out of salvage steel now we're sending
you back to your home forges where
you'll recreate an iconic weapon from
history
that weapon is
[Music]
the charade
the history of the cheray sword is
deeply tied to the violent history of
the kyber pass which separates
afghanistan and pakistan the sharp
single-edged blade was a key asset of
the afridi tribe the charade had
devastating consequences for the
afridi's enemies because it could pierce
through armor the distinctive t-shape of
the spine gives extra strength to the
charade's razor-sharp blade
good luck blade smiths
feels great being back here a nice sunny
jacksonville florida
my day one goal is to actually get this
blade forged
the only thing i'm really concerned
about
is getting the t-back of the spine
correct
i'm going to create this t-spine by
forging in fuller grooves getting that
correct is very crucial
not good
the problem is i put a little bit too
much pressure and it looks like it's
pushed through
it's too thin and i got a little bit of
daylight showing in there so
i am going to start over
i was able to finish up the layering
i got the overall dimensions forged out
but i've never forged the tee into a
spine before
if i was in an afghan desert
this is probably how i would
have to do this
so uh i
drew everything over length and then uh
just started to upset that spine
bringing it out in the shape of the tea
i think it's working great
i mean a nice even tea there
went way quicker than i thought it would
it allowed me to get to the quench today
seems like everything went well
but as i was trying to pull it out
boom
[Music]
after yesterday having to trash my blade
i really need to get this blade done
today
so far so good
looking pretty awesome
forging in this t-joint
is a lot harder than i thought it was
going to be
so today i'm using my other option which
is the grinding wheel this is very
crucial i really can't afford to have to
do this blade over again
as i'm grinding in the tee i noticed
that it's standing out way better than i
ever thought i can control it a lot
better everything's getting a lot
lighter and i am very happy at this
point
[Music]
when i was quenching obviously the blade
fell
but i got lucky
everything's fine so i'd like to get
through some testing early this morning
failure during testing here
would give me only 14 15 hours to build
a complete char-a
so i don't need a failure here
oh yeah
ate that up absolutely no problem
[Music]
this blade looks extremely sexy
i'm just going to concentrate on doing
my handle scales inlays
cleaning up the blade a lot more
i decided that i want to carve a wolf
head in the front of it just to kind of
set it apart make it stand out
my wolf looks badass
the blade sharp the blade's strong it's
time to test it
all right here we go
[Music]
it's pretty good there's no edge damage
or anything
just bring it on man do whatever you
want to do
awesome
bladesmiths the charade was a weapon
known to be light fast
and sharp to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon can do i will take a
charade and deliver slashes and stabs on
this ballistics dummy
steve you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
wow
well steve i like the damascus pattern
and overall it's got a great fit and
finish
your edge
definitely lacerated
it even cut into the rib
on the slash it lacerates and has a deep
thrust it allows me to disembowel this
ballistics dummy your blade sir will
kill
thank you ryan you're next you ready
yeah man
well ryan let's talk about your blade
for cheree
it is heavy but it's sharp enough to
lacerate
and dig in and the thrust allows for the
laceration out
your blade sir will kill
all right gentlemen now to test the
sharpness of your blade i'll be cutting
through these racks of sugar cane
forehand and backhand what i want to see
is a clean cut with very little
resistance to that blade
steve you're up first you ready yes sir
okay
[Music]
all right well it felt good cutting with
this
you can see these first cuts very clean
this second cut i kind of
blew through this one you can actually
see where the tea back smacked that
sucker now that's typical of this shaped
blade well done thank you all right ryan
you're up you ready for this do me pro
so ryan first off there's a lot of
weight in this blade that t-back is
there to take weight out
but everything's still right and tight
it obviously cut pretty well
cut two of these canes kind of just
mashed that one out of the way but you
can see the cut in there is clean
i like the decorative pieces you know
this wolf's head here
all
she's a cutter it's definitely sharp
all right gentlemen next up the strength
test it's the bullet test so let's clear
the range and get this set
now we've got your blade steve locked
into a vise we're gonna fire one round
right at that edge
if everything's good you should split
that bullet fine
you ready for this yes sir okay
three
two
one
fire
oh look at that
well
you still got an edge there you can
actually see
right where the bullet
spun down the side of that blade
i see where it caught the tee back on
that side
but i think you uh
made a beautiful piece here and it
certainly held up in that test thank you
sir
all right ryan you're up are you ready
for this let's do it
three
two
one
fire
[Applause]
[Music]
damn
all right ryan i don't see any damage at
all that bullet painted your blade
pretty good
didn't touch the
the tea back on this side kind of caught
a little bit on that side but all in all
there's zero edge damage there
nicely done thank you sarah
bladesmiths
these decisions are always tough but the
judges have made one
there can only be one forged and fired
champion in this arena of competition
and that champion is
[Music]
steve
congratulations you are the forge to
fire champion
thank you ryan
i have to ask you please render your
weapon
fortune fire champion would have meant
the world to me but you just really have
to be on your a-game you know no matter
what it takes you just got to pull out
all the stops you got to make sure look
at the finer details and
you know that's what it takes to win
this
steve congratulations you are the forest
of fire champion and that's a title that
comes with
ten thousand dollars good job
thank you
thank you steve your blade was light
well constructed and it did wonderfully
in the tests and also the fact that's
the first time you've done a tea bag it
makes it that much more impressive well
done
i am a fortune fire champion
yay
i came here to prove that i can compete
with some of the best miss in the world
and beat him and i did just that
you